what are you excited about right now in
terms of deep learning sighted about
this machine translation even though I
myself haven't made any direct
contribution to it some of my students
are doing it I think over the fairly
short term we're going to get much
better translators yeah I am excited for
things like understanding documents I
think there's going to be huge progress
there over the next five to ten years
instead of giving Google some words and
they they'll find you all the documents
have those words in you give Google some
themes and it'll find the documents that
are saying that even if they're saying
it in different words and so you're
going to be able to search for documents
by what it is the documents are claiming
independent whatever the works are that
would be kind of useful
you